deux tiers des français n'ont encore
jamais surfé sur le web et pour la
quatrième édition de la fête de
l'internet
vous pouvez gratuitement pendant tout le
week-end vous connecter et partir à la
découverte du réseau mondial mais malgré
cette fête du net le moral n'est pas
vraiment beau fixe au sein de la
nouvelle économie
plusieurs start-up qui ont trop vite
grandi y ont fermé boutique
même si ce n'est pas encore la fin de la
belle époque reportage dominique vadel
didier la charmoise la musique
d'ambiance dans la salle de rédaction de
ce magazine est terriblement tendance
nous sommes dans un des lieux branchés
de la net génération
ici on ausculte tout ce qui se passe sur
internet pour le publier et avec 76
mille exemplaires mensuels
ça marche plutôt bien l'une des tâches
des rixes est observée à la loupe
l'univers de la nouvelle économie
et surprise bien décide qu'il recherche
ont déjà disparu
bref après des années de rêve l'univers
des start up compte ses morts
licenciements et plans sociaux
inimaginable il ya un an
apparaissent aujourd'hui
c'est pas une crise économique comme a
pu l'être la crise de l'industrie
textile géré une fin de règne difficile
la fin d'une époque là je dire c'est le
début d'une époque c'est tout le
contraire c'est l'écrémage naturel et
après les meilleurs survivent
ce magasin d'informatique est l'un des
plus grands du monde c'est même
paraît-il le troisième lieu le plus
visité de paris après la tour eiffel et
l'arc de tripes
ici les affaires marchent et ce n'est
pas fini en france 8 millions
d'ordinateurs sont connectés au net par
comparaison ils sont 19 en allemagne
la marge de progression des ventes est
donc énorme et depuis un an
elles sont dopés lapointe est un compact
est en cours sur les shows les péchés
bureau et sur le second trimestre on a
eu une évolution plus soif profonde
portable lui qu'on ne présente plus
c'est le pape de la comme patron du tout
nouveau deuxième groupe mondial de
communication
s'il ne surfe pas sur le net il le
dévore et il le répète la crise est
passagère
internet est une vraie révolution qui
bouleverse tout grâce à l'accès immédiat
au monde entier là on peut mettre en
oeuvre les bonnes idées directement
niveau mondial donc le petit sur
internet et la bonne idée continuera
toujours à bousculer les plus grands
dans les années qui viennent j'en suis
convaincu d'autant que l'avenir est
prometteur puisqu'on prévoit plus d'un
milliard d'utilisateurs du net dans le
monde
en 2005 la saison